[Music]
How is Cristian Cásseres greeting you with
his brief News Now program in
Spanish? The Las Vegas Metropolitan Police
is investigating two
accidents involving pedestrians.
The first happened
Thursday night around 11:30
on the street.  fourth and prayer in the
center of the city a 67-year-old man
in a wheelchair fell on the street
one of the drivers stopped to
assist him while another driver
ran over him when he did not see him, taking his life
ten minutes after this incident
one  woman was struck and killed while
crossing bskyb semi near spring
mount ser the driver was arrested and
is suspected of driving under the
influence of toxic substances
and tonight the golden knights will play
their third game so far the
series goes from 2 to 0  with the nights
losing against the co they managed to
speak however Friday night
was magical since the bovine scam will be
working  at 100% capacity for the
first time after reductions in
health restrictions
remember that those who are
fully vaccinated will not have to
wear a good mask I leave
football here the light laws will be
playing their first home game of the
season on  Saturday from
7:30 in the afternoon during a
conference the team revealed that they are
eager to finally play in front of their
fans
inside the cash pension visit and
disney.com diagonal in Spanish for more
information and the heat wave continues to
sweep through the  valle today we will have
another hot day with temperatures
reaching almost 109 degrees we will
continue with some extreme heat alert
until saturday but we
will have temperatures in the 90s again for
next week i am cristian cáceres with
your previous news now in
spanish
[Music]